Gamescom day two I'm here with sub four
I'm Peter Brown we just saw Dead Island
2 in Deep Silver and Yeager yeah it is
super Ellie built like alpha pre-alpha
it's it's super early but yeah we were
running around Los Angeles we had two
weapons and we were doing a lot of
killing well so we had teams of four but
the game will eventually support a
player's the point is appointed co-op of
zombie-killing yeah slightly reminiscent
from left four done I was getting us a
glass a dead vibe yeah left for dead
vibe so I mean you know while left for
dead felt like it was a little bit more
linear in the way it was guiding you
around stuff we had a big area to
explore filled with things you know that
you could modify your weapons
collectibles loot like stuff from you
know Dead Island that we know yeah but
the area that you have to sort of
operate in is pretty big pretty open
right yes very large they're a lot of
houses a lot of different you know
businesses like a gas station and movie
theater yeah things like that and you
could go into all of those and explore
all the different crevices and collect
resources to upgrade your weapons yeah
you mentioned that you got an
electrified knife with yeah Beauty girl
cared yes so we that we have two
characters we had the I forget a name
but she was she was nimble she wasn't
rex start stunt coordinator yeah and she
was sort of like the agile but slightly
weaker character in yeah you could
modify her nights that she had by
collecting a series of batteries from
from a store at the beginning of the
demo okay and then you could modify her
other weapon which was a pistol or
revolver by collecting enough fuel at
petrol station up at the top of the
but yeah the other character was the
tank character how'd you how'd you find
him
uh well I'm definitely a tank I mean he
was kind of you know really slow really
strong in a giant mallet for his melee
weapon and then a shotgun yeah for his
primary thing I miss all the upgradable
stuff but you told me that you were able
to get the I got them all home both of
those dudes like it was like a fire
modification where you get a fire mode
for the sledgehammer so when you were
doing your heavy attack and sort of like
a sweet lift you saw you squeeze it yeah
I mean you can send me like 30 feet up
in the air yeah and they believe a nice
fiery trail as they went and then we
could Electrify his shotgun as well
which I didn't really see much
difference it just seemed to up the
power a little bit the strength of it
sure but that was all it really did but
one thing that was nice that I noticed
as well as as I set fire to one of these
zombies he landed in the grass and the
entire lawn in front of this house
caught fire and killed a couple of like
idling sort of slower zombies as well
yeah there were a lot of little nice
effects like that yeah I think the
divine environment could have been a
little bit more destructible but again
it's free alpha or alpha yeah Los
Angeles there's San Francisco and one
last location Zoo yet-to-be-named
presumably California definitely ones in
the west coast it's not London I don't
know it might be lettuce it's usually
love it's usually one but they yeah they
have one challenge towards the end as
well which was we had to defend a movie
theater I believe yeah I mean
essentially we were just standing there
and they had waves of zombies coming
faster which again another left had any
kind of feel of like come on team get
together let's get this done yeah
although there whether the team is there
or not the the challenge went ahead and
I think like three people defended it
successful like two people defended
successfully so but yeah there were a
couple of things like I set a trap by
accident on a on a car I could pop the
body open and like hit the engine and
it's sort of like did you all that by
accident I just did it those are
multiple steps because there's a little
icon on the bonnet it's like well what
does this do okay nothing here and then
he blows up them but yeah there were a
couple of different zombie types as well
there were Walker there was a really
large kind of hulking guy thug I think
he was sure
he did a lot of hits like it took like
multiple people you know a couple of
minutes to get that guy down and then
they had the I don't want to say boomer
no but that's kind of an archetype
insider Suicider I think it's caught
this all right yes he's like pus-filled
giant wobbly thing it comes like idling
over and then we'll just charge you in
and then the sort of sprinter star ones
to this place be like younglings newly
turned they still have fleshy legs I
mean look we haven't had a new game
that's sort of like left for dead in a
long time yeah and I think what Dead
Island 2 is doing with the setting and
the themes is really light-hearted it
sort of meant to have fun so they can
mix those two you and develop them a
little bit more
I might actually find myself playing
this game I didn't like that first one
yeah no I was the same and I think when
we got the other two characters play as
well and you get that full you know like
you're saying four players all right if
you because they're saying it you can
get each of the four characters in and
see maybe how they their strengths work
together because we weren't really
playing much as the team everyone kind
of yeah shut off in their own directions
but if we've got all four characters at
some point I'll be interested to see how
teamwork
works and I think this is one of three
darling games and development right now
there's epidemic escape from Dead Island
ends at Island - and don't forget dying
late which was sort of dead I went to I
never would and now it's not anymore
certainly lots of zombie games we're
gonna be checking out some more games
Compson stay tuned again
[Music]